oh what is it
some sort of energy field
be careful rambo
captain rambo watch it
[Music]
[Applause]
tomorrow nothing can prepare you
for what's next
marvel studios one division now
streaming
only on disney plus how's it going
everybody it's warren welcome back to
the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things
marvel and everything relating to the
marvel cinematic universe and we just
got an
official clip for one division episode 4
coming out tomorrow or
very late tonight if you're going to
join me for my watch party and this
official clip
does confirm that episode 4 is going to
be from the perspective
of sword this confirms that monica rambo
is indeed going to be one of the major
players
in this show randall park is going to be
it with his character jimmy wu that we
saw in ant-man and the wasp and darcy is
back
as well now a few key scenes here are
one
it looks like monica rambo can actually
simply
just go through this energy field it
doesn't seem to be preventing her
from going inside of it in any way it
more looks like sort of a camouflage
because if we look through the energy
field everything looks normal
then we go to a scene where darcy seems
to be examining
wanda and vision and we see a bunch of
different pictures of a bunch of
different people
on the wall now all these people are
from the town and it looks like they all
work for sword and this makes sense
because it does appear like sword could
simply just send people inside of this
force field but one thing this does do
is confirm that sword is not the people
responsible for putting her inside of
here because as we can see they stumble
upon this force field
but this could actually be a major
reveal
in this shot where it shows all of the
different sword people
as you can see sword has their profiles
of everybody and it looks like they also
have their identifications for them
their licenses
this is most likely because they take
them before they enter
this force field this energy field and
they go into the town
but if you notice agnes does not have
any type of identification on her
profile which basically confirms that
agnes
is not working for sword this is even
more proof that she is indeed the witch
agatha harkness and if she is not
working for sword
who exactly is she working for well most
likely the demon
mephisto and this pretty much all but
confirms that she is indeed act of the
harkness
and as expected it was jimmy wu on the
radio
asking wanda who is doing this to you
and he's asking that from outside of the
energy field
so as i've been talking about for a few
days now we are going to be getting some
big reveals in episode 4
coming in less than 24 hours so final
chance to drop
all of your speculation and theories
about episode 4 in the comments down
below
don't forget to join me in my watch
party tonight it starts at 3 a.m eastern
time so be sure to subscribe and hit the
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos and the
watch parties don't forget to like the
video for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof